okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about writing equations in
slope-intercept form so just to review
here we've got y equals mx plus b this
is our slope intercept form and when
you're doing word problems or story
problems on the act you want to think
about the slope as the rate okay like
the rate of change or how much something
costs per hour you're thinking about a
rate and then the y intercept or the b
value think of that as the initial
condition or the starting amount so
let's go through a couple examples and i
get a feel for how this works so go
ahead and pause the video see if you can
do
each of these examples and we'll go
through them together so the first one
says judy has run 30 miles so far this
year
if she runs two miles a day
what equation models the number of miles
that she runs m
after w weeks okay so number of miles is
m and the number of weeks is w
okay so how would you do that one well
instead of thinking of y equals mx plus
b like we normally do we're going to
think about
miles as the output and now weeks is the
input but what we're interested in is
finding out what's the rate well she's
running two miles a day that's her rate
but in terms of weeks okay she's
actually running 14 miles
per week so that's going to be 14 times
the number of weeks but she's already
ran that's her initial condition
30 miles so far so plus 30. so for
example if 10 weeks pass
she'll run 10 times 14 140 plus the 30
that she's already run 170 miles so
again when you do these problems think
of the slope as the rate okay and the y
intercept as the starting amount or the
initial condition okay example number
two try this one on your own if after
two hours the water level is at five
feet and after five hours the water
levels at 11 feet
how many feet will the water level be at
after eight hours okay so we're assuming
that this is increasing at a
linear rate okay a constant rate
and they would tell you that in the
problem
so in this example what we can do is we
can coordinate these points what i mean
by that is you say after two hours the
water level is at five feet and after
five hours the water level's at 11 feet
and we're wondering after eight hours
how many feet is it going to be at well
when you have two points like this you
can calculate the slope okay which is
the rate of change and you would do that
by
y2 minus y1 so 11 minus 5 over x2 minus
x1 5 minus 2 so that gives us 6 over 3
which equals 2. so what that means is
rising at
2 feet
per hour
okay now if we go to put this into our
equation y equals mx plus b
we know that y equals oops do y equals
2x
plus b we don't know what the b value is
the starting
level of the water but what we can do is
we can take one of these points either 2
5 or 5 11. i'm just going to use 2 5 i'm
going to put 5 in for y
i'm going to put 2 in for x and i'm
going to solve for b so we have 5 equals
4 plus b
subtract 4 from both sides and you can
see that b equals 1. so if we put that
back in here we've got our equation so
it's
y equals two x plus one after eight
hours let's put that in for x we get two
times eight is sixteen plus one is
seventeen so the water will be at a
level of seventeen feet so that's how
you would approach these uh linear
equation problems you want to make use
of the slope intercept form of the line
and pay attention to the rate and the
initial condition sometimes you have to
solve for that initial condition by
using one of the points that we did here
in example two
so definitely something important you
want to know for the ect